la staffetta che c'è il principe quindi
limitata di vela
[Musica]
ma la barba judas è in ballo faccio una
foto di me la madonna preoccupata dice
l'ho abbracciato scongiura e la tutti
ragazzi e minuti che sono video sono
famiglie
oggi siamo su uil su trophies quest
videogames è uscito ragazzi warface
questo per il videogame stato in
italiano dalla madonna hanno fatto un
salto di qualità c'è persino in coreano
fantastico non ho la più pallida idea di
quanti livelli ci siano però vai al
gioco e fonde sega ai creatori di questo
gioco vi porgo il mio pisello hanno
fatto guardo fuori kraft all'inizio
quanto li possa amare no va bene che
hanno un ciclo continuo e lì ci sono
dieci livelli o che va bene dal primo
world of warcraft perfetto il portale ti
porta in un'altra regione che non è
proprio il cesso prova vecchi chiamo il
sesso
cos'è allora non ti fa andare va bene la
cosa che devo fare è prendere sicuro la
bomboletta perché amava cliccare ok
adesso ci salgo sopra lui la gaffe dj
usa la sua per l'amor di dio hanno
sputtanato world of warcraft in un
secondo meraviglioso o queste porta la
prima cosa che notiamo assolutamente che
vi salta agli occhi è sono i pantaloni
moda 2016 milano fashion week somigli
veramente a mio prozio pino che devo
fare quando piccola torta
[Musica]
lo sai che questa bellissima pistola
potrebbe sbadatamente entrarti nel culo
non lo so se lo sai facciamo c'è
qualcosa che non vedo tipo questo posso
sparare i portali bellissimo per chi non
conoscesse portal allora si sparano due
portali uno blu e uno arancione se entri
nel portale blu finisci dal in quello
arancione quindi dove sparo sto portale
dovrebbe finirci qua il parassita in
teoria potrebbe titolarsi posso fare
così anche con le verifiche di
matematica bellissimo mi sorprende
sempre di più la genialità di questi
videogames ragazzi non ho idea di che
cosa sia via insulti fa vige non sai che
cazzo è sta roba
no ragazzi ovviamente perché quant'è
brutta notizia per fare devo aprire le
scatolette di cibo perché anche secondo
me qua e dove finisci center in quella
botola di prima devo aprire le quelle
verificato delta caso dei periti
trovarci il manzotin dentro che cazzo
vuoi che ci trovi sonde mosche
apprezzate al rumore che fanno ste mossi
bellissimo
[Musica]
hanno bevuto vodka pesante stemo schermo
e sono fermi ma grande è il
giusto gioco ma ha fatto conosco pure
qualcosa fatto non riconosce la
grandezza
poi magari non è così sticazzi questo
non credo sia assassin's creed mi sembra
più un mi sono fatto di ketamina creed o
una roba del genere cosa posso provare a
fare di stilo i pantaloni un vero
assassino semper fidelis sempre scure
giuste scotta fra penso che non perché
vi incazzate tutta salute
[Musica]
sapete che quando siamo andati in
giappone sasha scoreggia va una volta
ogni tre secondi ecco avrei voluto
reagire così però la boe ho capito fermi
12 e adesso tra pinter cool e no pensavo
che scoraggiasse quello del carlo del
fieno hanno sbagliato ad oggi non era
quello che volevo fare scherzavo bisogna
fare a ok io merito ai pensando se la
prendessero comunque non è il caso va
bene non importa non ho parole
perché tu perché ma poi perché sassi
capelli salveti osha dei capelli più
belli mio padre non cambiare arma sicuro
lo sapevo lo sapevo non fa una piega zio
veramente non fa una piega
[Musica]
il fucile spara polli tanta roba ragazzi
ma poco tanta non solo ma fatta non
venirmi in mente prima che cosa dovrebbe
essere questo sorriso più falso di
quando si costretto a sorridere nelle
foto di classe e un orgasmo regala cosa
può fare
devi avere un successo con le donne come
pochi plastic ore che cosa devo fare
cosa mica c'entra con minecraft sta roba
vi prego fatemi cubi ma santo iddio devo
cliccare qualcosa che non vedo cosa che
si fa in minecraft sini premuto ma era
la virtual reality su main cup in realtà
stavo pagando per terra non stavo grande
pubblico preferivo di zombie sincero
perché mi sembra vagamente doc di
ritorno al futuro me lo metti sulla bici
ma che sicuramente più colto della mia
tesina di maturità ragazzi importante
andare avanti ea minchia non se lo
aspettava da una vita tra il pi on trade
and tra le gemme vi assicuro che se
tutto è ancora peggio zio c'e veramente
come livello fallito ho capito fermi
sono sicuro che c'entra con la barra
della vita due cliccare sulla barra
della vita convinto mi abbasso no crolla
il filtro laghi sono il carattere fra
chi diventa il vero che l'ho anche detto
mi abbasso comunque andiamo avanti
legami mancano due mancano questa e
quella dopo
finora comunque sono state meravigliose
tutte quante quello conosciuto gioco è
che perché il mio simulator guadagna i
big money ragazzi non so voi ma io
questo lo chiamo click bates nel mio
paese funziona dire così questo video è
un click gate o click day tappa dai ke
kazzo può arrivare a 100 aces titoli che
devo arrivare a 100
quanto ci fate che si arrivò a 100 perdo
cosa ci non scommettere le mutande sono
in mutande sono in mutande
se arriviamo al 100 mele tolgo e non
credo sia una cosa buona
pronto a si salve le apro che la
l'hamburger che aveva ordinato scusate
devo aprire in mutande a quel tizio liga
gli ho fatto vedere la mercanzia come
mancia comunque torniamo a noi
sarebbe stato troppo bello che faccia
disposizione meraviglia il più bello di
me la mattina e ce ne vuole
clicco questo affanculo cosa cliccato
elsa kiss jack allora santo iddio e
trascino al 10 trascino come qua chi
appunto a paritaria
semplicissimo ma te caga gozzi un eto'o
l'ultimo livello il gol simulator sto
gioco merita la vita ci siamo ragazzi
allora devo far atterrare la capra ok
poco ho già vinto
ho già fatto giusto non so perché sono
nato sono andato da dio in questo
preferisco e se l'unico della vita ce
l'ho fatta
non ci posso credere mica il primo
tentativo fa vedere casuali e stato
superfigo tratto che lo avevano finito
con un record di click
ma ecco che ha fatto sto già facendo mi
chiamo giocava al milano una volta quale
ragazzi questa è la trans face quest
videogames spero che vi sia piaciuto
ragazzi cose treviso piaciuta sono un
bel pollici in su è capace di facebook
come vidotto tale descrizione che ho
dato la mancia al cameriere quindi devo
andarmi a
gustare questo bel panino siamo vestiti
iscrivetevi e noi non ci rivediamo non
possiamo vino ragazzi volevo fare il
figo porca eva
beh ragazzi